Hi Data 2100 students, welcome to
your first in-class assignment.
With in-class assignments,
I want you to try the in
-class assignment on your
own, and then I want you to
come back and watch the
video if you have questions.
So please, go ahead, try the in
-class assignment on your own.
Come back to the video if you
have questions and want to
verify your answers. But trying
it first and then coming back
with questions of what you did
and did not understand will help
improve your learning experience.
As a reminder, in-class
assignments, I want you to feel
like you're in class with me.
I will make mistakes, sometimes
on purpose, a lot of times not
on purpose. I will fix them and
we'll work through them and we
will talk about errors and
encoding and it will feel like a
live class. So I really want you
to watch this video, but after
you've tried to complete it on
your own, it's really important.
So let's go ahead and jump into
our first in-class assignment
that you've already tried on your
own, right? Alright, so let's jump
into those learning objectives.
By completing this assignment
you will demonstrate understanding
of Excel worksheet structure,
rows and columns, cell
referencing, essential
Excel functions like average max and min,
data quality assessment
and identification,
basic
formatting in Excel. So we
are going to work with a data
set containing information
about online course enrollments.
This data includes student demographics,
course progress, and completion
status. You'll practice your Excel
skills. You're going to turn in
this Word document file and the Excel
file. So download this Word file,
download the Excel file, and
then we're going to rename
them to last name underscore.
So you're going to
put your last name there in
the title of the document.
Then submit both files in Canvas
for me okay all right so we're
going to understand the data set
first so we're going to take a look
at this provided Excel file ICA
Excel and data quality so here's what
our Excel file looks like we
have the user ID the course name
enrollment date completion status
and on down so as a reminder these
are all rows right I'm gonna zoom
in here these are all rows and
these are columns so I have my
different column headers here, like user
ID, course name, enrollment date,
completion status, those are
all describing here the data points
for each of these different records.
These are all, each of these
rows represents a student, and
they're in specifically here in this
data science basics class, okay?
So we are going to go ahead
and look at the metadata.
The metadata means data about the data.
So what do the data points represent?
So rows, each row except row one
represents one student's course
enrollment. The columns, each
column represents different
information. So we have our unique
identifier, the name of the course,
when the student enrolled,
whether or not it was in
progress, it completed,
they dropped it, the
percentage of course completed,
things like that. So we have
all of these different columns.
We then also have
after we've looked at our
data set which we have we
now have these tasks to
complete in this assignment.
So task number one is we are going to
create a sheet in the Excel workbook.
So I'm going to create a new
sheet in the Excel workbook. We're
going to rename the new sheet to
practice sheet. Now again if you've had
experience in Excel you're like Reagan
this is a little simple and you're
right it is simple but we are going
to continue to weave Excel in and
out through this class as we focus
on our core concepts of databases,
programming, and data analysis.
But it's important we start off
with a way of looking at data
that we can interact with. So
I'm going to go ahead here and
create this Excel spreadsheet. So
I'm going to click on this plus
sign, this new sheet down here
in the bottom left-hand corner.
So I see here I have sheet 2.
Yours may see sheet 1 because
I accidentally created another
one. I'm going to right
-click, and I want to rename
this to practice sheet. Okay?
So now I have two sheets in my
Excel workbook. I have sheet
ICA Excel and data quality,
and then I have practice sheet.
Okay?
In cell A1 of the practice
sheet, type the number 5.
Okay? So in cell A1,
we know what A1 is. We
know how to identify
that. I'm going to type 5.
In cell A2, it tells me
to type the number 10.
Okay, perfect.
And then what it tells me to do is
I am going to select both cells, A1
and A2. And I'm going to use the
fill handle, the small square in the
bottom right-hand corner of the
cell, to drag down and automatically
fill the series up to 200. So my
list is going to show 5, 10, 15, 20.
This is teaching you that Excel's
autofill feature recognizes
patterns and can extend a
series of data automatically.
So I'm going to highlight these
two data points, okay, and then you
see this tiny square down here.
I'm going to grab that and drag it
all the way down to where it says
100, so that would be at 20, okay.
And so now I have 5, 10, 15,
20, and on down to 100. So
Excel automatically recognizes
that pattern and will allow
you to continue that pattern
using that autofill tool.
I could do the same thing over
here if I wanted to, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
If I just put 1 and 2 here,
gave it the context of two
cells and copied it down,
it would do the same thing.
So really, really helpful.
Okay, perfect. So we have done that.
Check.
Task number one is good to go. We
have six of them. Let's keep going.
Task number two, we're going
to calculate the average age.
Okay. So what is the average
age of students in the data
set? So it's here in cell
H21. We are going to, so I'm
going to come back here to the
ICA Excel and data quality.
I'm going to take a look at my age here.
Now I'm going to give you a tip.
here if I if I don't want my first
row to disappear because it kind
of drives me crazy if it does I'm
going to click on that one line
I'm going to come up here to review
oh sorry nope to view my apologies
I'm going to say freeze panes
I'm going to freeze that top
row okay so I clicked on the row
that I'm wanting to freeze I
went to view and then freeze pane
click the drop down, freeze top
row. So now, as I scroll down,
you can see that top row will
stay right there. Okay, perfect.
So as I scroll down here,
in cell it told me, now I'm gonna forget.
so I'm gonna type average
age into cell G203, so we can
come here into cell G203 and
type in average age, okay?
Then over here in cell H203, I
wanna calculate the average age.
So we already learned about
this, right, in our lecture
video, so I'm gonna say, I'm gonna
start off by saying equal to,
then that tells Excel
I'm gonna do a formula or
a function, and I'm
gonna start typing in AV,
and I'm gonna grab this average
function. I'm going to double click
that or you can just hit enter
once it highlights it and now I'm
going to grab all the data the whole
range of which I want to have of
which I want to calculate the average
for which would be all the data
from cells h2 to h2o1 right I want
to calculate the average of all
of the students' ages, okay? So I
am doing that, and it's going to
perform this function on that data,
and then I'm going to hit enter,
okay? So I have an opening.
You'll notice an opening and a
closing parentheses. I hit enter,
and the average age is 40.54.
Perfect. So now when I come
back here, what is the average
age of students in the data
set? The average age is 40.54.
Perfect.
Awesome. Now we used a
function. Perfect. Task 3,
right, we're on to task number three.
We're going to add percent signs
to progress data. So in column E,
we're going to select the progress
percent column data and then we're
going to change it into a percentage.
So we can do this by right
clicking after selecting column E
and choosing format cells and
then in the format cells dialog
box changing it to a percentage.
So I'm going to click here
on column E, I'm going to right
click and say format cells
and then I'm going to
click on, because right
now here I'm looking
at a bunch of different
decimal points regarding the
percentage of progress the students has
made in the class. I'm going to come
here and click percentage and the
decimal points I want it to be one.
So I'm going to press okay and now I
can see that the progress percent
has all been changed to percentage
signs so it's a little bit easier
to interpret rather than just those
decimal points. Again, I can do this
by again clicking on E, right click,
format cells,
select percentage and the
decimal places being number one,
okay? So now I have properly
formatted that E column according
to the specifications here
on my in-class assignment.
So Excel will display the
numbers with percentage signs.
The underlying values don't
change, only how they're
displayed, okay? So just keep
that in mind. Now on task
number four, I want you to
identify the data quality error.
So I'm going to examine the state
column, column K, carefully.
We're going to look for inconsistencies
in how states are formatted.
Some states are written
as full names while others
use abbreviations. Also
check for extra spaces or
unusual formatting. So let's
take a look in column K.
So I'm going to come over here to
column K and I could scroll through
all of this if I wanted to, but
I'm going to use my handy filter
tool here which is going to allow
me to just look at all of the
unique values that I'm given here.
So I can see here that I have
Arizona, CA, then California, then
FL, Florida. Well, CA and California
are the same state, but they're
just written in two different
ways. So that's interesting to note.
Same thing with Florida and FL.
Huh, that's really interesting. So
what type of data quality issues
do I have going on here? Well, I
have a consistency issue, right?
And let me go ahead and select
these cells so I can look at CA in
California and then FL in Florida
and then Georgia in Georgia. I
can actually look at those too.
Let's look if there's any others.
And we have New York and New
York. I only need to identify one,
but we got a lot. New Jersey
and New Jersey, Texas and Texas.
All right. So if I take a
look at this here, now I'm
showing these different rows
that some of them say, again,
New York, some of them say
NY, and some say New York.
So we need to make sure that that
is all consistent. So I'm going to
point to, since the majority of the
other states are all spelled out,
I'm going to say that the data
quality, one example is in K8.
All right, so which cell
includes the error? So I
can say cell K8 includes
an example of the error.
K8 refers to, or K8 reads NY,
or I'm going to say K8 contains NY
while most other state, well, let's see,
while contains NY instead of New York.
For consistency,
all, and follow along here with me,
make sure you're doing this with me.
So for consistency,
all two-letter abbreviations should be
transformed into the
full name of the state.
We could say all two letters should
be New York, or all two letters
should be transformed into their
state. Or we could say, you know what,
instead of spelling out the whole
state name, we're just going to use
a two-letter abbreviation. Either
way, it just needs to be consistent.
In this case, because the
other states, most of them are,
it's their full name, right,
Massachusetts, Michigan,
Maryland, those things, I
said to spell out the entire
state. So with that, now I can
select all of my data again,
but do you see how helpful that
filtering is and recognizing
that's a data quality issue
because it appears as such NY
is different than New York,
okay, according to the data.
Okay, perfect.
The description of error, we
included that up above. And I
can also say, there are many
examples of the two-letter
abbreviations in the data. They
need to be changed to the full
state. So I gave you one example
of K8, but there's other ones.
all right instructions uh we're going
to look for logical inconsistencies
in the data pay attention to the
relationship between completion
status and progress percent columns
think about what it means for a
course to be completed what would
you expect the progress percent to
be so let's go ahead and take a look
at this so i'm going to come over
here i'm looking at completion status
and then i'm looking at progress
percent okay so let's take a look
at this so if i Uh-oh. This is
weird. So I have completed here in
cell D3 for this one student. Okay.
But then the progress percent is
a 52.5%. What? Well, but it says
the course is completed. So why is
the progress percent? Well, that's
an issue. That's an issue going
on for sure. Same thing down here.
Okay. So we have some really
interesting, I also have some data
quality issues going on here. This
one says it's 2,000% completed.
That seems, something seems wrong there.
Also, completed looks
like it's, well, it says
completed, but yet the
progress percent is at 0.1%.
So we need to point this out.
This is a data quality issue.
So here I'm going to say,
I'm going to say rows.
Instead of this is cells,
I'm going to say rows. I'm
going to say rows. I'm
going to say row, let's say,
for user ID 14491, okay?
So which cell includes the error?
Specifically, what is its cell reference?
So the cell reference of
that is specifically E3,
okay? So I'm going to say
in E3 for user ID 14491.
The progress percent is,
what was that percentage,
52.5%, yet the completion,
yet the status is complete.
um this is a data quality issue
as the progress percent should be
a hundred percent if the class is
complete it is recommended that
we look into how the progress
percent is being calculated okay
So we should take a look into
that. Maybe it's that it's being
calculated in a different way.
Maybe it's not syncing properly to
however we're receiving this data.
So this is a data quality error.
Those two columns are saying
two different things, right?
Okay,
awesome. So I have the description
of the error happening there. I could
also say here, this is happening
for many other records of data too.
Okay,
perfect.
Now in task 6, here in column
L, we're going to create
a new column. So we can
come over here to column
L. It exists, but we're
going to name it something.
We are going to see how each
student's quiz score compares to the
best quiz score in the class.
So we're going to think about it
like this. If the highest quiz
score in the class is a 95 and a
student scored 76, they got about
80% of the top score. Okay, so
76 divided by 95 equals 80%. So
we want to look at how does each
student's quiz score compare to
the highest quiz score. Okay,
so we're going to create
the header. We're going
to click on cell L1 and
type performance score.
Okay, so that's going to be my
column heading for this new column.
Perfect.
We're going to start with the
first student. Okay, we're
going to click on cell L2.
Okay, so we're going to click
on cell L2. So I'm looking
at this first student here.
And we're going to build the
formula together in parts.
So we need the student's
quiz score, which is going to
be G2. So I'm going to say
equal to G2. Okay, that's
this student's score. so I'm
referencing that cell, okay?
Then what I need to do is we need to find
the highest quiz score in all the data.
Hmm, you're right. So
let's, we're gonna say equal
to, instead of just G2,
we're gonna say equal to max,
and then somewhere, and then
we want to find the max of all
of this quiz score. So from
G2 to G201, we want to perform
this max calculation on this
range of data, okay? So we
can say equal to G2, G201. So
what is the max quiz score?
when I hit enter, we're
going to see that the highest
score is a 99.5. So that is
my highest maximum score.
Now, we found the highest quiz
score in all the data. Now we need
to divide the student's score by
the highest score. So let's go ahead
and do this. So here when I say
equal to max, I found that maximum
value. And this is where Excel
and its formulas can get really
complex but really, really helpful.
We just piece them together one
step at a time. So I found the
maximum, but now what I want to do
is I want to say equal to G2
divided by the maximum. So I want to
take their quiz score divided by
that maximum score to figure out
how did their quiz score compare
to that top score. So now I hit
enter, and I see that their performance
score was about a .30. zero.
Well, as we can see here, I
want to actually make this
into a percentage. Okay. So
I actually want to make this
into a percentage. So I can
multiply this by a hundred.
So I'm going to go ahead and
do that. So I can say times by
100 and I hit enter. And now I
can see here that I have 30.05
is the performance score
for specifically this
student. And as I double
-click, so let's do that again.
So I double-clicked this,
and it is going to calculate the
performance score for
all of the students.
And as it does that,
so if yours took a minute to
calculate, that's kind of normal
because it's calculating that max
inside of that calculation. right
it's calculating that max inside of
that calculation but you'll notice
here though we have an issue going
on don't we because now since i had
to do the same thing for this student
we'll notice here that that max
calculation now starts at g3 instead
of g2 right i still want to find
the maximum quiz score for all of
the quiz participants. So what I need
to do here, this is why we always
double check everything, is I need to
make this G2 through G201 an absolute
self-reference. You can also use
a keystroke to do that quickly. I'm
going you go ahead and hit enter.
And so now when I double
click this down, it's
going to take a minute
to recalculate that.
But now it will only use that
range of all of the quiz scores,
right? Because we have it set up
as an absolute cell reference.
Prior, it was just moving down
that calculation so that quiz
score, the maximum calculation
started at cell G3 and went down
to cell 20 something that doesn't
have any data in it, right?
So we always need to verify that
we're using absolute relative
cell references as we need to, okay?
So now as we do this, if I double
click here, I can see, oh
yeah, it says G2 divided by the
maximum of this value. Perfect. I
can come here. Now it's doing the
same thing. So it's using the same
range to calculate the max for
all of the different records here
instead of just that first one.
We could have also calculated
the maximum value of the
quiz scores out here and then
reference that value. You
can do things like that to
improve the processing time.
But I hope you found that
to be a helpful exercise.
Then you'll notice here, right,
the dollar signs lock this
part so it won't change when we
copy the formula. So we needed
to verify that we did that,
right, and we did that just fine.
So we'll notice that what
happens when we copy, G2 becomes
G3, G4, right, this is relative,
It moves with each row.
G2 through G201 stays exactly
the same. This is absolute.
The dollar signs lock it in
place, okay? So now when we
look at this, we can see
here that the person with the
highest performance score, if
we take a look, is going to be
the person that scored that
99.5. So where are they at?
There they are. Perfect. So there's
our person that scored the 100%,
meaning they were the highest
score. So everybody else is based
upon a calculation of how they're
scored compared to that highest
score. All right, everyone. So
we're going to go ahead. I want you
to file and save as, and then make
sure you do file, save as, and
say Sigurd underscore, but it's
going to be your first name this
time. I'm sorry, your last name,
not my last name. So do your last
name, save the Excel file, save
the Word document file, and submit
both of them into Canvas, and this
in-class assignment is complete.